Corrección política
es la enemiga de la política,
porque queremos que sea todo tan,
tan impecable,
tan incoloro, inodoro e insípido,
que la gente ya no sabe lo que compra, ¿no?
Y en relación eh con esta especialmente no,
porque durante
50 años, pues el temor
ha hecho que vayamos escogiendo de Tal modo
la manera de expresarnos
para no molestar
a quienes eran los poderosos
y los poderosos
eran los que tenían las armas y los que aplaudían,
¿los que tenían las armas no
y a los que estaban de acuerdo
con el proyecto político que defendían
los terroristas? No, entonces nos hemos ido
eh acomodando esa
corrección política
y bueno, pues tenemos el el resultado que tenemos, ¿no?
Que al final en en el en el País Vasco,
quien ha hablado claro en relación con con España
y con la libertad,
pues ha ido disminuyendo su presencia
política en las instituciones,
no hasta llegar a mínimos históricos
como los como los actuales